jared what's your standout memory from
the super bowl
um
you know not very many good ones there's
not many parallels that you can draw
from that game in this game the teams
are so different the offenses are
offensive different their defense is
different
yeah i would expect him to say that uh
not many good memories and it really is
a different experience altogether when
you only score three points to cap a
season where the offense was one of the
most magical that we can recall really
the best rams offense since the greatest
show-offs on turf
to only score three points in the super
bowl not something you'd want to
remember even only two years later all
right some prop bets for tonight's
patriots rams game as always the odds
are provided by the points bet
sportsbook cam newton over under passing
yards the highly specific number of
185.5 chris what do you got i'm going
under here i i don't think this is going
to lend itself to
a lot of big plays you know the new
england show they're capable of winning
a game with cam newton throwing for 75
yards 68 yards whatever it doesn't
matter all the way it's just about you
know those handful of throws that are
going to be a third down are they going
to hit those during the game but i i
just can't imagine
many big plays happening uh for them
throughout through the pass game you
know
the the secondary for the rams is legit
they are really good and of course have
jaylen ramsey and guys that are going to
be able to lock up these patriot
receivers and staley smart 2 on the
defensive coordinator for the rams where
he's not going to put his guys in
man-to-man every play and do that he
plays a lot of cool zone coverages as
well i i would be shocked if he throws
for 185
84 yards a week 12 against the cardinals
69 yards week 13 against
the chargers and they still won 45 to
nothing so i agree with you it'll be
under that jared goff over under
265.5 what do you think he'll do i i
gotta go under there too that's just too
many yards for me i mean this patriots
they're secondary and then
then the added of you know we we've
talked about this before the the drop
back pass game and the mcveigh pass game
even off of boots and play actions is
not overly complicated you know it gets
complicated when you start they start
running the ball on you and then you
start going well wait i can't cover some
of those things because i need help out
on the run and that's when he's really
got you by you know the the proverbial
kahunas there um so i i don't think it's
gonna be that type of game no i would i
would have a hard time believing jared
goff throws for that many yards i'm
going under all the way there
jared goff has been spectacular on
thursday night football with sean mcvay
as the head coach i recall a game in
late september of 2018 where the rams
and goff shredded the vikings two and
one on thursday night football passing
yards per game 384
passing touchdowns to interceptions in
those three games nine and one and a
passer rating of 127.6 pretty damn good
i'm still going under because you know
what he hasn't played the patriots on
thursday night before so it's it's the
quality of the opposition that helps
dictate what kind of a game you're going
to have right i think super bowl 53 is a
lot more relevant to me than what day of
the week it is yeah i can remember two
out of those three games i mean one of
them was last year the seahawks write a
thursday night game which again you know
the seahawks defense hasn't been good in
five years so that's nothing to write
home about and then you know the game
you're talking about that minnesota game
that was the game that was one of like
early parts of our life together where
it remember what did they have anthony
barr covering robert woods 70 yards down
the field like oh yeah uh yeah but that
was that was probably one of jared
goff's best game of his career some of
the throws and things he did that game
were pretty damn special but that's what
we talk about there it's few and far
between of when we have seen that
yeah bar got repeatedly victimized that
night i think three touchdowns ended up
being scored by the guy that they
assigned a bar to cover and it's not
barr's fault he shouldn't have been
covering the guy all right more rushing
yards damian harris the patriots are cam
akers of the rams i'm going to go with
damian harris i mean he's their guy he's
their go-to running back and he is their
offense as far as yardage outputs
concerned so they're gonna feed him the
ball and he's gonna have opportunities
acres i think can have a solid night but
i just think there's gonna be more
spreading of the wealth within the rams
offense you know whether it's henderson
and then hey cooper cup and robert woods
and all of that to where
they don't have to ride one guy as much
as new england new england has to have
damian harris have a solid night if they
want to be in the game competitive
whatever i mean there's no other avenue
so i mean unless some other running back
goes off i don't know is sony michelle
100 healthy tonight can he play i don't
know i mean but uh i'm expecting damian
harris to be the guy
yeah you know i i ca i i feel like
they're moving towards
in in l.a yeah making cam acres the guy
so i'm going to go acres just because i
feel like that there that you know daryl
henderson is becoming the back up to
acres and malcolm brown is just the guy
who's who's there and it was supposed to
be more of a three-headed monster so i'm
going to lean acres more receiving yards
the over under for cooper cup via points
bet is 59.5
for robert woods it's 58.5 who has more
receiving yards
man
i i'm i don't even know there i mean
really if you made me pick
i'd probably go with like one of their
gerald everett in this type of game over
rather than these two guys because i
just would be shocked like if
belichick's the belichick's you know son
and father
let cooper cup and robert woods go up
i'll go with cooper cup
i'll go with cooper cup i don't even
know why i just feel like robert woods
you know the speed sweeps the bright
lights might be on him a little bit more
to where cooper cup gets some more
favorable matchups every now and then
i you know as i look at it i i think
they use them pretty much the same they
do see a difference in how they use them
no i think that's the beauty of it you
don't really you can't really
hold them to oh wait this guy does this
and this dot guy does that they're very
interchangeable the only thing i would
say where woods gets a little bit more
than cup is
woods is more of the speed sweep guy
they do use him more in that fashion but
you're right as far as the past game's
concerned and all that they have a very
similar skill set that's where that's
why it was hard for me to pick there i
don't i don't know
i'm who did i say i was going to go with
i went with um cup just because i think
he could sneak by there yeah i mean
that's that's a close one nitpicking
there
i think they're both going to be
are they both going to be under
that let's let's focus on that oh yeah
well i said which one's going to have
more but cups at 59 and a half is the
over under woods is it 58 and a half are
you leaning both being under that number
i think i am yeah i'm leaning both being
under and like you know i could see them
you know hey woods being at 54 yards
cooper cup being at 48 yards gerald
everett maybe has a few catches added in
there you know reynolds he gets involved
the backs get a few catches i i feel
like it's going to be that kind of night
rather than oh they're just you know
using one guy to abuse the patriots we
know the patriots don't really let that
happen
jared evert has a 24 and a half over
under four receiving yards tonight
more interceptions tonight of course
there's a chance they'll have the same
but stefan gilmore jaylen ramsey if one
has more than the other who will it be
i think if i'm gonna pick one i'm gonna
pick jalen ramsey
um
i i just feel like won't you just not
throw to whoever he's covering isn't
that what josh mcdaniel's the one
coaching point for cam newton tonight
never throw to the guy that ramsay's
covering
it it could be yes if it's man-to-man
and they see that you're right that's
probably gonna be a matchup they don't
mess with
maybe you might mic you i think your
thoughts right there i'm going to switch
that i'm going to go to stephon gilmore
i like that thought i think you're
exactly right and i mean whether it's
man whether it's zone wherever ramsay is
come out of the void first first look
for aaron donald then look for jalen
ramsey and make sure you never throw to
wherever jaylen ramsay is i guess where
i just went with ramsay a little at
first is
i just feel like
i just don't think the patriots are
going to run the ball run like at some
point there's going to be we got to make
a few throws or a few plays i just think
the rams 2 defense is too good to be
just blown out of the water in the run
game and that's why i kind of said the
the ramsey thing but your point is real
and i think they will be careful of them
and who knows if they throw the ball
enough anyway so because of everything
you just said you swayed me i'm gonna go
with gilmore if there's interceptions
gilmore's gonna get it
all right uh i'll agree with you as well
i agree with you you said it first yeah
i'll agree with you you agree with me
i'll agree with you we agree with each
other uh my my point is there's a chance
neither guy has an interest so i'm
thinking about just saying that it's
going to be zero um but uh but we'll see
it's it's i i'm excited for this game
tonight you know that that new stadium
hasn't been showcased the way that maybe
it could or should be it does stink that
fans aren't there hopefully by next year
that will be different but to see the
patriots and the rams on the field again
even though the rams have different
uniforms
uh there's going to be something special
about it i love these super bowl
rematches and every year you get a few
of them we're going to get one tonight
and it should be fun to watch
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports